I hope you're doing well I hope
everyone's doing okay I'm worried about
you everybody's scared are you scared
everyone's so scared nowadays ones so
scared some things are scary I guess
there's uh there's no grownups left
that's kind of scary
there's no adults left there's no one
left to fight the bad guys that's kind
of scary there's adult coloring books
now adult coloring books and they're
popular
I saw a man a man a grown man on the
floor of an airport a man laying on his
stomach on the floor of an airport just
coloring just
why even wear pants
my friends like no time you don't
understand they are adults I have one
it's a game of Thrones coloring book oh
my apologies I thought it was something
childish like The Hobbit I had no idea
it was Game of Thrones that must be
stressful with all the snow in that show
having to use the white crayon you never
really know if it's working or not
no one can deal have these these people
with the fake service dogs you see these
creeps fake service dogs there's real
service dogs that help real people then
a girl shows up with a Pekinese sticking
out of a Hello Kitty handbag and tries
to tell us it's working and then scams
our certificate to show at the gate I
have to have my puppy with me at all
times or I'm gonna lose my marbles oh by
all means welcome aboard what could
possibly go wrong with your crazy ass at
40,000 feet
one's a baby I have two kids and they're
going through a stage now where they're
starting to realize I'm not as great as
they thought you know three years I was
there God everything I did they were
just amazed he gets food how does he do
it
I saw him tie his shoes by himself the
other day I was yelling at him I mixed
up their names they shot me a look like
oh maybe our leader is an idiot
maybe he's not kidding when he says he
can't help with our math homework and
then they're not wrong I can't help them
with their homework 5th grade math I'm
out I'm out I can't do but I have to act
like it's a parenting decision for my
own ego they'll come to me like Jack can
you help me with my hallway no I'm not
just giving you the answers just between
you and your teacher work it out I'm in
the bathroom on YouTube how do you add
fractions with different bottoms
you just got to make them the same how
my role in the house might the way ups
remain useful is that I am the only dad
I am the only dad and that means I am
the only man because everybody in the
house is a woman I I made two people
they're women little girls my wife a
woman two cats women lizard sexy woman
and I am it I a man it's my job to teach
them that there are no great guys that's
my job there are no great guys I believe
it and I say it every day there are no
great guys American men are as great as
are gonna get we fight for equality and
we push strollers and we tell you we
want equal pay but keep in mind it's an
act it's an act inside all of us is a
16th century man
who wants to burn the village to the
ground there are no great guys my wife's
friends get married to a great guy he's
a great guy she's so lucky he's great
no he's not I haven't even met him and I
know he's not he might be great at
hiding his evil ways but he's not great
so keep that in mind if you have a man
you have a wild animal
that's a wild animal and you're in
charge so you use them wisely don't ask
us to do certain things don't be stupid
with your man don't ask us to watch the
children
what are you doing we're not really
watching the children not the way you
watch the children we watch them eat
bottle caps and fall down stairs and we
laugh
[Music]
don't ask me to shop with my 13-year old
I shouldn't be shouldn't being forever
21 waiting for my daughter to come out
of the dressing room no one there knows
I have a daughter in the dressing room
they just see a sweaty uncomfortable man
breathing heavy by himself next to the
bras and panties and I shouldn't pick
the young one up from gymnastics no
father should pick up their daughter
from gymnastics and I shouldn't be
hanging out with the other moms waiting
for it to be over
they're all talking about juice boxes
and playdates all I'm thinking is which
one of these moms would I have sex with
first we being honest that's where our
head goes now which one would I have sex
with by the way cuz I'd have sex with
all of them the weird one the one with
the thing on our eye I'll make it work
I'll make it work thank you so much
you